true Gamers will do just about anything
to get an edge because sometimes a
regular old setup just won't cut it some
people look for the perfect settings
simple settings simple settings
others try to get their mice and
keyboards in just the right position
horizontal uh keyboard takes up too much
space on small land desks and I have
this much room and still others look for
the perfect position for themselves
there's only eight man right it was only
eight man it was single elimination what
is he doing oh my God the new tech did
you see that they put the warnings on
the monitors you gotta measure the
distance between you and the screen
but all these attempts at challenging
the gaming status quo pale in comparison
to the things Dylan rudism Beck has both
created and played with over the years
don't do it I'm gonna die I'll go I'm
looking up and down and everywhere
oh man this is tough right
yes
ah I did it okay I'm happy
um I first started doing this kind of
thing because it was silly and dumb and
I thought it was funny I first started
playing with just bizarre controllers
that already existed on stream like
guitar controllers and steering wheels
and stuff like that and I did that
basically because my friend dared me to
rudism is twitch's Premier gaming
inventor a master of crafting the most
absurd ridiculous controllers you could
possibly imagine and then somehow
actually succeeding with them so how
exactly does someone end up using fruit
to play a video game where do rudism's
crazy ideas come from and is there more
to his insane controller designs than
meets the eye it works
[Music]
okay so before we dive into rudism's
story I must humbly request that you
please like the video subscribe to the
channel and turn on notifications also
be sure to check out the new line of
merch we put out just a couple of weeks
back they sent me one of everything and
I can honestly say buy us aside that the
fit is fire if any of you are a tall
King like myself I'm almost 6'5 I really
enjoy how long the clothing is it's
really spacious and well designed and
well made and just buy some anyway we've
all seen those videos of people
attempting to play video games with some
weird ass controllers but even amongst
these convention breaking Rebels there
is a Madman who took the entire concept
to its absolute mind-blowing extreme
keep calm
yes yes yes yes
yes
[Music]
debate rudism has made a twitch career
out of building the absolute most cursed
controllers humanly imaginable and then
not just playing games with them but
playing them well now obviously using
food and other household objects as
gaming input devices isn't exactly
mainstream and yet in recent years
several content creators have taken up
the mantle and added the creation of
shall we say unusual controllers to
their regular lineup jeez man this
controller feels so weird look at this
but when rudism first decided to give it
a try playing rocket league with a
Guitar Hero guitar with documented
attempts going back as far as 2015. it
was essentially unheard of I from what I
understand I don't think there were any
sort of gaming content creators that
were building their own custom
controllers around the time that I
started to do it of course back then
rudism didn't know that his entire
stream would soon be devoted to
regularly turning random objects into
usable gaming Hardware
[Music]
instead he actually dreamed of being a
rock star
sort of as Rudolph the akiwi I'm Aussie
no oh God I'm never gonna live that down
I have a habit of saying the opposite of
what I mean to say thank you so much for
the four years I'm going to quit twitch
forever now goodbye rudism started out
playing competitive Guitar Hero he
attended National tournaments in his
native New Zealand and in 2010 made it
all the way to fourth place in a Guitar
Hero 5 tournament at the world cyber
games in Los Angeles only just missed
the podium by literally this much but uh
that's okay I'm still pretty happy with
that after that little setback rudism
kept at it for a couple more years and
since he was already devoting a good
chunk of time to practice he figured
he'd also stream his sessions to anyone
who cared to tune in but in an attempt
to separate himself from every other
review starved twitch streamer out there
rudism's friend dared him to do
something a little
different because I think I was playing
rocket League one time and my friend who
happened to be watching the stream at
the time he's like oh you should play it
with a guitar they'll be that'd be dumb
and I'm like yeah that would be dumb and
I kind of laughed it off at first but
then we kind of actually talked about a
game plan of how it would actually work
and then tried it out and it worked
really well from then on every day
rudism strayed further and further from
God daring to go where no other
controller wielder had ever gone before
he began constructing the weirdest
controllers imaginable every creation
stranger than the last originally I
wanted to do
um peanut butter so play Winston with
peanut butter but it turns out the
peanut butter isn't a very good
conductor of electricity because
um it doesn't it's quite oily so it
doesn't really do much in terms of oh
hello ultimate time the I was in the
supermarket yesterday I was looking for
a fruit or vegetable that I could play
Tetris with
legitimately the the idea of the
eggplant came last here's my controller
it's got a trigger right there a
thumbstick for aiming but it has motion
control so I can aim using that too
no
thanks to some of buddhism's more
unconventional offerings his follower
Circle slowly but surely expanded Beyond
his IRL friends and in 2017 he even
netted himself a world record for most
goals scored in rocket league with an
instrument controller now at this point
you probably understand why rudism
became Gaming's most cursed controller
Constructor what you might be wondering
how does he do it does he get those
wonderful toys well you see rudism
didn't put all of his proverbial eggs
into a single basket
like any ambitious inventor brutism had
a backup plan let's just say that rudism
didn't quit his day job he actually has
a degree in computer science and game
design is his full-time gig now you
might think that designing games and
designing controllers to play those
games would actually have a ton of
crossover
and that's partially true but just
because rudism knew how games worked
didn't mean he knew how to turn a jelly
bean into a joystick that he had to
teach himself yeah when I first started
building controllers myself like I knew
how to program them from my game
development but I never learned how to
build them on a hardware level so that's
something I've basically been
self-taught in but along the way like
I've luckily managed to attract some
people into my community who know a lot
more than I do rudism's willingness to
try pretty much anything opened the door
for him and his expanding Community to
come together and bring more crazy ideas
to life after all what's a streaming mad
scientist without an army of twitch chat
assistants to help him out the best
ideas come from when you bounce them off
other people so like if I'm ever
streaming and I have an idea that comes
to mind I'll just say it out loud and
then someone else might have a
suggestion that makes it better or you
know someone will throw an idea at me
and I'll be like okay what if you do
this and that could work really well
there we go
oh look at us being farmers
bloody fantastic but of course while
there were pretty much no limits to what
rudism and his fellow controller
masterminds would cook up on his stream
let's just say that not everything he's
built has ended up working out like the
time that rudism tried to play portal
with a squishy grocery store treat I
tried to play portal with a cake and it
was kind of like designed to look like
the actual one in the game so there's
like a lot of fake cherries on there and
stuff and all those factories were the
different inputs for the game the whole
thing kind of just disintegrated before
I was able to finish the game I think I
got about a third of the way through
which honestly is not terrible
considering the control scheme and even
then the controllers that were of
success didn't always come together
perfectly apparently if you just throw
something at another thing the bloody
thing the uh Circle doesn't pick it up
so and I lost my balance after about 10
seconds solves this guy like just trying
to prop myself up on this thing touching
balls to a screen I'm like this is
[__] stupid this is really really
dumb but no matter how things shake out
rudism isn't afraid to test the limits
vis-a-vis what's possible with his off
the wall ideas after all it's not just
that he finds crazy ways to play it's
that he manages it with some of the
hardest most competitive games out there
and outplays people who use the intended
peripherals and this is how we score a
goal the [__] rocking horse boys and
girls but not everything rutus makes is
designed to be competitive in fact his
most insane controller to date is
designed for a single player experience
and this workout intensive monstrosity
is his pride and joy I built a control
for Untitled Goose game out of a big I
won't say it was like a motion control
suit it was kind of really rough the way
it was put together but I basically had
motion sensors in my hands and feet so I
could like flat my wings and walk around
I had a microphone attached to like a
cardboard beak so I could like do voice
activated honking
um and yeah like I was just trying to
play the game with that I can't believe
this works
it works
it was one of those things where as soon
as I actually started to play it like it
did the first like kind of honk on
screen and it actually did it in game
responding to my voice and then like the
flapping and I was able to walk around I
was like okay this is something that's
gonna like this is gonna work this is
gonna be perfect and yeah that was
probably the one I was most proud of I
think up to that point because yeah it
was just a huge huge Gamble and it
worked but aside from the obvious
entertainment value there's more beneath
the surface the more practical
application for controllers that stray
away from the ordinary I'm talking of
course about the issue of accessibility
in gaming it's gonna become a real
um eye-opener for me in terms of here's
this thing that I did for fun but
actually there's some real world skills
in here that could benefit a lot of
people so it's something I've been
thinking about a lot and something I'd
really like to have a go at properly
even though it wasn't his intention at
the start by devoting time and effort to
exploring the idea that you don't need
to be able to use a controller or a
mouse to play games has occasionally
stumbled across Concepts that could
potentially help Gamers who might have
trouble using conventional Hardware move
forward
stop it strong attack
Hammer Time
ladies and gentlemen
what's controlled Skyrim accessibility
in game is massively massively important
thing that I've think about a lot now
more than I ever have like I've been
doing a lot of fundraising stuff for
ablegamers and things like that too and
I'd encourage anyone who's interested to
Chuck a dollar their way because it'll
go for a really good purpose and um yeah
I'm hoping I can do more of that in the
future would be fun but for the time
being rudism is focusing on improving
the durability of the stuff he already
plays with like building his own Guitar
Hero controller to replace the one he
first started out with because as fun as
using a stick of butter to game may seem
there comes a point where you want to be
here for a long time not just a good one
it's kind of a nice full circle thing I
think you know I started out with a
guitar and I've been using it for years
and now it's like now I actually build
my own one kind of a culmination of a
lot of things like it's that whole
durability thing you know trying to make
something that actually lasts a long
time and it's the first controller I
ever use and I'm making my own one you
know I kind of like it from a um
sentimental point of view whatever the
future holds for rudism's channel it's
undeniable that his Ingenuity has
highlighted that there isn't a single
right way to play you can spend your
entire life optimizing your setup and
still have an absolutely miserable time
maybe you'll never play CS go with a
kumquat or something but the fact that
there is a guy out there who's showing
everyone that it is possible to have fun
no matter what you're playing with
is something truly special rudism is
living breathing proof that you don't
need to have the world's greatest setup
to succeed in game or on Twitch you just
need to have some Ingenuity a little
creativity
and a willingness to look
utterly ridiculous this by the way is
the most advanced controller I've ever
built and it's a [__] baguette
every creation more [__] than the last
seeing the words Apex with a mannequin
leg
when I see these kids playing in these
[__] gold novas now I understand you
know what some of these get the like
that's gotta be what's going on you know